sin empezado a desvelar esta mañana las
medidas diplomáticas de castigo contra
eeuu que había prometido adoptar la
primera y que se daba por descontada son
las sanciones a la congresista nancy
pelosi y a sus familiares no ha querido
concretar pekín en qué consistirán esas
sanciones sí que ha aclarado que se
deben a sus actos hostiles y
provocadores con los que ha violado el
principio de soberanía territorial pero
si se convirtió esta semana en el más
alto cargo político de eeuu que pisaba
la isla lo que generó la furia inmediata
de china en total son ocho medidas
contra eeuu y que también incluyen la
suspensión de la cooperación bilateral
en asuntos como la repatriación de
inmigrantes o la lucha contra el cambio
climático y el crimen transnacional
mientras tanto en el estrecho de formosa
se cumple el segundo día de las masivas
maniobras militares esta vez como un
castigo para taiwán y que parece que
siguen la tónica del primero unos diez
barcos y unos veinte aviones habían
cruzado este mediodía la línea media que
funciona como
oficiosa según el ministerio de defensa
taiwanés
pekín ha aclarado que las maniobras
continuarán hasta el mediodía del
domingo